good morning good morning good morning
good morning wow it looks like Tim Cook
is about to break his good morning meme
streak because out of nowhere Apple has
just confirmed their October 30th scary
fast event at 5:00 p.m. yes 5:00 p.m.
which means he's going to be saying good
evening for the first time and if that
timing sounds weird to you it's because
Apple has never had an event that late
in the day so in this video I'm going to
explain why apple is choosing that weird
time slot as well as precisely which new
Apple products we should expect to get
released as far as the 5:00 p.m. timing
it's likely Apple just experimenting
with a new time to see if it boosts
engagement and viewership and yes the
Apple event invite icon turned into a
Mac finder icon which was the biggest
hint that we are in fact getting new Max
but in terms of the new scary fast
tagline one thing you might not know is
that when they released the new M1 Pro
and M1 Max chips their marketing
materials literally said scary fast for
the M1 Pro and scary faster for the M1
Max so I guess next week's launch should
be scary fastest because I think this
hints at a new fast chip reveal now I've
got to admit guys that at first I
thought that maybe Apple would release
two new IMAX based on the M2 series of
chips but that was quickly shut down by
new rumors and input from Mark German
saying that it would be a terrible
self-inflicted letdown if Apple did this
leading to lots of disappointment and
then out of nowhere mink chaquil
completely flip-flopped on his previous
prediction of no new Max coming through
the end of the year and basically
admitted that Mark German was right the
entire time saying that new M3 series
MacBook Pros are going to be the main
focus of this event now his explanation
for flipping his prediction was that the
MacBook supply chain looked like it
wasn't going to have very many sales for
the fourth quarter which is why he
assumed there would be no new Mac
products coming but seeing as these
high-end MacBook Pros don't really sell
in massive volumes anyway because
they're expensive it probably wouldn't
move the needle very much anyway in
terms of having a big change in
shipments so what exactly does that mean
which M3 series of chips are coming and
which products are they going into well
apparently the new M3 Pro and M3 Max
chips going into new Macbook Pros
according to Mark German who has been
saying this for a while because the
custom configurations of those MacBook
Pros have been seeing really bad delays
and late shipment dates but the weirdest
part of all is the timing of these new
Macbook Pro updates next week because
Apple usually waits around 6 to 9 months
after they release the regular M chip
before releasing the pro and Max
versions and we haven't even seen the M3
chip yet and even weirder it's only been
9 months since Apple released the M2 Pro
and M2 Max MacBook Pros so why in the
world would Apple release two updates
within the same calendar year it just
sounds absolutely insane it doesn't seem
to make any sense but I've been trying
to think of some reasons for why and how
this could make sense and I've thought
of a few of them first of all Mark
German pointed out that the M2 Pro and
M2 Max MacBook Pros were actually
supposed to come in October of last year
instead of this past January so it
should have been one year later for
these new new Macbook Pros for reason
number two tsmc's 3 nanm n3b process has
had some really bad yield issues leading
to less supply of chips than Apple hoped
for so what if they're intentionally
using the bad yield m3b node for the M3
Pro and M3 Max chips specifically
because this product doesn't sell that
many units so it's a perfect match
especially since N3 B is actually more
performant than the future generation
n3e chips that we're expecting next year
so what if apple is planning to delay
the regular M3 chip until early next
year and then builds that on n3e which
has better yields before finally
building n3e into the iPhone's a18 Pro
chip next year maybe that's the case but
it's probably likely that apple is going
to announce the regular M3 chips next
week as well keeping it limited to the
13-in MacBook Pro and maybe an M3 iMac
just so it doesn't seem weird to not
release the regular M3 while releasing
the M3 Pro and M3 Max he also did
specifically say that the MacBook airs
are getting delayed until next year for
sure so we shouldn't hold on to hope for
those ones next week and then for reason
number three Ming quo just basically
confirmed that the M2 series of Max have
not been selling very well at all due to
not having a big enough performance jump
so Apple could essentially be conceding
to the consumer and Calling it Quits on
the M2 series of Max choosing to skip
straight to the M3 family earlier than
previously planned in a desperate effort
to Boost Max sales so with that said it
seems the most likely that we get the M3
Pro and M3 Max MacBook Pros with the
possibility of the 13-in m M3 MacBook
Pro and maybe the M3 iMac so they could
finally switch everything over to USBC
in terms of the magic peripherals this
scenario was honestly the complete
opposite of what I was expecting due to
Apple's tendency to stretch out the
releases And Delay things but if it's
true that Apple's Mac sales have been
tanking due to the lackluster M2 series
chips then I can definitely see them
choosing to say screw it and just go
full force on M3 to help boost sales
again especially right before their
earnings release which could look very
Bleak for Mac sales now with all that
said what should we expect from these
new MacBooks and chips well as far as
the design of the 14 and 16-in MacBook
Pros we shouldn't expect any changes at
all the design will likely stay the same
as before with updated internals once
again with the possibility of one or two
bonus surprise features added in but who
knows as far as the M3 Pro chip itself
Mark German has seen developer tests of
this chip and configurations of either
12 or 14 CPU cores which means that the
base model will come with a 12 core chip
comprising of six performance cores and
six efficiency cores while the upgraded
M2 Pro will have eight performance cores
this by itself will lead to an awesome
performance improvement over the M2 Pro
chip which only received two more
efficiency cores compared to the M1 Pro
and then of course we need to add in the
gains from tsmc's 3 nanm chip designs
for even more performance and as far as
the graphics performance we're only
expecting to get two extra GPU cores so
don't expect a Major Performance jump
there but the M3 Max is where the fun
will really begin blowing away tons of
people with its huge performance
Improvement this ship will have 16 CPU
cores but in a much more favorable
layout actually coming with an
absolutely Bonkers 12 performance cores
while keeping the same four efficiency
cores as before this right here will
create a chip so powerful that it'll be
almost as fast as the current M2 Ultra
chip in the Mac Studio which is two M2
Maxes put together this Chip is going to
blow minds and it's all also probably
going to hurt the sales of the M2 Ultra
Max studio and Mac Pro but once again it
looks like the sales have been so bad
that Apple's willing to call it quits on
the M2 series and go straight for the M3
so if you're as excited as I am for this
October event go ahead and subscribe
above for our coverage and in-depth
reviews and comparisons with these new
MacBooks and definitely check out one of
those two videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next
[Music]
video